これじゃあはじめシャツはですゴールデンウィーク付録
言われたゴールデンウィークなんですけどまぁ日曜日有料化の悠遊カードこう引退でに
行ったんですけどもう結果は
準優勝でしたさ
[音楽]
ブーバーしかああっんぬーんっにょいいんじゃなくて
ちょちょっとパパっていうのともっとて人になります今日はじゃあこちらです
みんなの卵数道がもうねちょっと切れちゃってるんですけども
卵があるんだけどもうちょっと言わせて聞いたんですけど他の魂の
手で握っても割れないらしいです今日ねこの俺様な
実際にこの魂も手でね
th
[音楽]
ぜひ今日はねこのハンティングでね卵
縁あってやろうと思います
[音楽]
何か入ってない結構賞味期限きれちゃってるか生きてるかもしれない私は記事いうこと
が生まれないもの
あのマジで何かわかんないだろチンピラてんだがどうかわかんないけれどもネットで
聞く限りなんかこの二点だけじゃはれないって聞いたんで
を卵で腕だけで待ってみようと思います
[音楽]
ちょっとキミが入ってたらよ呼ばれる日々が生えててもて言われるのは全然触れたけど
もこの
普通の状態ではイラクどうかって言われると俺は分からない3
0まあ
えっ
つまり等ございます
やっておめでとうございます
ああ
ええええええええええ
えっマジではれないんだけど
俺が言われた数で割れない
待っておれないんだけど
ピタッ
交われないよっ
みたいですね
[音楽]
あああ
いっ
ええええええ
ていた
[音楽]